you said earlier that you're hard on
yourself do you give yourself permission
to write badly at first you know there's
that thing where just like get it all
out on page the first draft it's going
to be horrible but you have to get that
in place or do you do you find yourself
really censoring yourself
I have tried you know for me my own
journey right now as a writer I have
tried to be more and more imperfect as
I've grown as a writer you know I've
tried to be better at letting things go
and and and and I'm not sure whether
that's a maturing process as a writer or
whether that's simply specific to like
my own kind of like journey you know
I've recently been really kind of
inspired by films that seem imperfect in
a lot of ways and that's kind of like
inspired me in some ways what's
imperfect about the characters or the
actual story I think they're imperfect
in in the traditional sense of like you
know not all the sound is pretty now the
picture is pretty you know some things
are not you know you can tell that
they're lacking in budget or whatever
but it's got so much so much heart you
know so I don't know you know I mean
some films kind of find that in editing
you know it's really kind of a strange
filmmaking is kind of a strange thing in
the sense that what the audience sees
and what the audience either admires or
does not like some of those are happy
accidents and some of those you know you
might find a shot in the movie that's
really inspiring and you're like you
know that's genius how did that come
about and like well that happened by
- then you know or vice versa you know
you might have something in there that's
that's you know amazing and it doesn't
work and they spent you know you know a
lot of time on so it's it's really kind
of a strange thing because you know I
don't know I mean intention and the the
producer or the filmmakers intention you
know that relationship with with with
the final product I don't know it's kind
of a strange thing yeah I can think of a
few films where I see the boom like
where it's a film and I still love it
yeah or the ending is very unclear i but
it actually keeps me right oh wait but
what if I wonder how that turned out
right the movie 2 came out four years
ago I was on the iPhone tangerine you
know I mean I mean I don't know what the
reception was of that movie I saw that
movie and I was inspired by that movie
simply because you realize that how
accessible storytelling is in some ways
you know gladiator you know but at the
same time you can't make an iPhone movie
for every single script I mean it works
for a certain type of story you know it
works it worked for that story because
the story was so kind of like gritty and
immediate and accessible um so it worked
for that you know so
you